thanks so much guys for meeting me today  I'm so hungover had like eight vodka  sona's last night maybe nine oh my god I  know I wish whiskey whiskey boy downtown  and Benton after hours I can get home to  like 5:00 in the morning already guys I  met the cutest guy at a club last night  it turns out he has a private jet  we're going to Hawaii next weekend oh my  god  else ha ha I can come home with you Oh  actually this morning I was changing his  diaper and I found a whole blueberry  inside like a whole thing and I even dug  it out I like totally dug it out and saw  all the sides of it and it was perfectly  round and I still can't figure it out no  doesn't even want bread sure get you  some